this is about the players and the
preparation
this isn't about
my career my my eight years in new
england this is about
the titans in our preparation to go up
there and
you know face a team that's won three
super bowls in the last five years
they're eight no
at home
in that span
at the number one defense
the best coach got the best quarterback
so it's quite a challenge
mike frable coach of the tennessee
titans on what is coming on saturday
night as the titans go to new england
and there is this sense chris that mike
frable's inside information will help
that preparation but preparation only
matters so much when it's single
elimination time there are some teams
that thrive on that and some teams that
don't we're going to find out what kind
of a team the titans are going to be
because this is their opportunity this
is it are they going to be a team that
wins in january under mike frable or are
they going to be the latest victim of
the terminator and you could tell by
frable's attitude there yeah he buys
into my theory the terminator's never
dead of course and the worst thing you
can do is assume the terminator is dead
when he's not and that is the patriot
well he understands the dna in which
which makes the patriots and how special
they are and that they're special with
their breakdowns and you know in these
playoff game scenarios
one not only have they shown the ability
to think outside the box and do
different game plans and things like
that two
their that winner go home attitude that
we just talked about in the tv opening
right mike i mean that's when teams take
chances new england's been one of those
teams that takes more chances than
anybody out there
but having said that i mean who's the
better team who's the better team that's
where this is interesting i mean when
you really go through it you just start
to go
man the titans are better than the
patriots in a lot of areas they are i
mean okay running running back running
game we're taking the titans quarterback
right now who are you taking i know it's
playoffs and
go ahead it's good this is a good guy i
want to have this convo
ryan tannehill yes now he only started
10 games right but he led the league in
passer rating and and look i understand
that some people don't like passer
rating and i think maybe people don't
like it because it's not zero to a
hundred but it's been the standard for
evaluating passing performance based on
yards per attempt completion percentage
touchdown pass percentage pass
interception percentage for years for
decades that's the nfl standard and ryan
tannehill had the fourth highest of all
time for the season this year behind
only peyton manning and aaron rodgers in
2011 nick foles in 2013. there's brian
tannen up 117.5
and tom brady was at the bottom of the
pack yeah this year in passer rating so
the better quarterback in the regular
season was ryan tannehill period right
so i'm just going through it here
because
i mean like you said and i'm with you
mike the patriots are the terminator
they you know you can never count them
out they're a different i mean they're
they're special they're on like their
own pedestal in the nfl but you start to
break that down and then you go the
offensive line well you go well titan's
offensive line is better you go
receivers you go well titans receivers
are better you know get on the defensive
side of the ball and of course the
patriots secondary is better but it's a
you know that much greater than the
tennessee titans is it that much greater
to where new england's offense can take
advantage against it so when you just go
on paper guys on the field from that
standpoint you sit there and go the
tennessee titans can definitely beat the
new england patriots now going up to new
england and doing is a whole different
thing and i give them a little bit more
of advantage because of like what you
said a minute ago mike vrabel knows some
of the tricks of the trades the things
new england might like to do in these
situations when they want to throw a
screen pass when they want to bring all
out blitz he'll know certain little you
know telltales that he knows from his
years there to go and dean pease along
with that to go oh
i know belichick and mcdaniels like to
do this during this little
game plan specific area whatever it may
be third and long i like they like to do
this second and ten they do this you
know there's gonna be little things like
that and nuances that they'll be all
over too and i think that's why we've
seen new england and them struggle
against some ex belichick coaches
yeah and i i agree with you completely i
i think that mike frable's knowledge of
the way patriots do things is an
advantage but how you use it and whether
or not right bill belichick counters
that you know
and we've seen belichick struggle
against some of his former assistants or
i mean frable was never an assistant
there but he was there long enough to
know how things are and how things work
17 postseason games played with bill
belichick and the patriots he surely
gleaned something about preparation
about decision making about tendencies
if bill belichick has any but i think
the key is going to be this and i think
back chris to 10 years ago yeah when the
ravens went into foxborough in the wild
card round right and trounced the
patriots the key is you've got to kill
them early yep you've got to get
especially this edition of the patriots
because they are not built to come from
14 17 21 nothing 100 and ba and and
that's exactly what the ravens did 10
years ago when the patriots were built
to come back they still were in such a
hole they couldn't get out of it if you
get that two score three score lead over
the patriots within the first half of
the game then you have a much better
chance to beat them and finally kill the
terminator yeah no that's exactly right
and you're right it's not uh easy to do
certainly and the patriots defense is
still special with what you know steve
belichick and of course you know father
bill have done this year and the
creativity of the things they do on the
uh defensive front and secondary and all
of that yeah i mean they deserve a lot
of credit and that's gonna be a pain in
the butt from the tennessee titans but
they have this great run game in
tennessee right now and derek henry i
mean we could sit here
what you could talk about with tennessee
was also interesting is you could argue
they got the hottest running back in
football they got the hottest
combination between quarterback and wide
receiver in football right now between
tannehill and aj brown and you know
we've talked you and i about lack of big
people in new england this year on the
defensive side i i do think about like
ray rice running up the middle that
first play in 2009 like you're talking
about you know i would not be shocked if
we see derek henry having his way here
the the titans can schematically put the
patriots into a bind and i think that's
what's interesting and uh but doing that
up in new england and outperforming and
out executing is a whole different
question
and i i wonder whether or not we're
going to see mike frable empty the tank
early right with
some trick plays with some
unconventional things aimed at
basically going all in and trying to
build that lead or do you just rely do
you go to your guys and say we're the
better team here we're gonna go execute
we're gonna do it systematically and
we're good enough that when we get to
the
the closing moments of the fourth
quarter it's going to be obvious that we
win the game i mean is he going to feel
that urgency that desperation to try to
engineer a big lead early or does he
just hope and believe that his guys are
good enough to to build and hold a lead
i think that's really the challenge for
him as a coach because i i think if he
tries to get into that that you know
back and forth and gradual process you
leave the door open for the patriots and
then tom brady's going to morph into
post-season tommy and it doesn't matter
that he was near the back of the pack
during the regular season he's going to
kill you in single elimination football
right or do you go all in with some
risky maneuvers early on to try to
deliver that death blow so you can't get
killed by the terminator in the fourth
quarter i think that
from a strategic standpoint
that's a that's a tough call and i could
see it go either way well yeah because
you could sit here and like we were just
talking about they i'm sure tennessee
can look at it and go
we're the better team i think you know
we're the better team we can beat these
guys do we need tricks do we need to do
something crazy
you know that that's the the argument
they're gonna be kind of in with
themselves
i guarantee you the new england patriots
are gonna have some trick plays this
week i can guarantee that for whether
it's either like you know oh gosh we're
struggling on offense we need to jump
start ourselves do something like that i
mean that's what we've seen in the past
from new england when they feel like oh
we're a little behind the eight ball and
this team's out playing us like that
2014 ravens game i always think about
that but i think like you know your to
your point like build and hold a lead
you know with this with this titan's
past defense it's not great right mike i
mean we've seen people have success on
them all year and i that would scare me
that would scare me you're right like
brady and the passover's not as good as
years past but against this past defense
you know if they're down 10 points i
would you know they can come back so i
hope for abel does have some tricks
some trick plays whatever it may be to
either
you know
put the what do i want to say put their
head on i mean put their foot on their
throat and end it or or at least have
something there to jump start them in
case things are stalling out on the
offensive side of the ball
and this is not going to be an easy road
for the patriots they win this game they
go to kansas city next week where they
barely escaped last year with the afc
championship and then unless there's an
upset they're going to have to go to
baltimore
where they lost by 17 points on a sunday
night earlier this year
and i
i you know
for other teams
for teams that that aren't as mentally
tough and resilient i'd say there's a
chance they lose
this weekend simply because they know
the road is going to be too difficult
but because it's the patriots because
it's bill belichick because it's tom
brady because there's this sense that
maybe it is all coming to an end and
eventually it will come to an end and
there's been this looming since the last
few years that it is if this really is
the last year for tom brady with new
england patriots whether he retires or
goes somewhere else i just feel like
that's all the more reason for them to
muster everything i'd be scared to death
if i was a titans fan i'd be scared to
death about this game because it's a
game you should win
but
it's the patriots and we've seen it time
and again and i don't know how you get
those 53 players and the coaching staff
to ignore that because it is a very real
factor it's never going to show up on
film no it's never going to show up in
the playbook it's never going to show up
in the stat sheet but it's a very real
dynamic to walk into that situation
knowing that you are going against one
of the most accomplished teams in the
history of sport when it comes to
thriving in this kind of do or die
setting yeah well i mean i i that's very
real and you feel it when you're there
just you know in my own experience as a
player it is you feel it when you walk
in the stadium and it's only intensified
since they've you know won you know six
of these damn things now so uh there is
a mystique there
but
they got perfect people to
drive home the right points with vrabel
and dmp's see you know for one to just
say hey listen to like what you're
saying they're the new england patriots
they're gonna if we're up by ten they're
gonna come back or they're they're never
gonna die
this is gonna be a four-quarter fight
they're the ultimate four-quarter
organization that we've ever seen in the
history of the nfl so he's gonna have to
beat that home but also tell them you
know don't
don't be afraid of the we can beat this
team like to almost you know
not make them this mystical mythical
creature to a degree i think he's got to
do a good job of going okay yeah it's
new england i see the logo on the helmet
but this guy's out here these receivers
we can cover them you know these d
linemen our alignment can block them
they're not like you know they're not
terminators we can we can stop them and
uh i think that's what he has to beat in
their brain a little bit
and it's a it's a tough balance because
i'm sitting here envisioning mike vrabel
in team meetings all week long showing
film of screw-ups mistakes blunders by
the patriots all year long that would
cause the guys to not be in awe of them
but at the same time you can't let your
guard down yes right that's the balance
yes they're just men
but they're not yeah and it's right but
they're special men would drive me crazy
no they're just men but pay no attention
to what happened when those men did that
great thing there but look at what they
did that's bad but you still want to
respect them but you don't want to be
scared of that it's it's
it's verbal right it's but but i still
we're going to be making our picks uh
later this morning the joint pft pm
chris sims unbuttoned mega pix podcast
for each of the wild card games and i've
been going back and forth on this one
all weeks yeah i still have more time to
go back and forth let's take a break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports